Các bạn có cào mời nhất của cuộc thống K cho thấy trong 12 năm 2020, có khoảng 1 phẩy 8.6
sự thánh in Việt Nam từ 12.5 đèn 2020, đình 20 tuổi không đi học cũng không đi làm,
chiếm mười phẩy 1 phần chăm tổng số thánh in. Tỳ lệ này cao hơn ớ nước giới và khu vực nông thôn.
Đáng chú ý, tỳ lệ thích nghiệp trong nhóm phánh in tiếp tục tăng, đặt tám phẩy 1 xin phần chăm,
cao góp gần bổn lần tỳ lệ thích nghiệp chung của cả nước, 2 phẩy 20 phần chăm.
Chồng ý đó, số là động có việc làm trong cả nước ước tính là 5.2 trộng người,
tăng nhẹ sò với phy trước và cùng khi năm ngoan.
Mặc dù vậy, thị trường là động vẫn chưa phát triển bên bưới,
khi là động phí chính thức còn chiếm tìm trọng lớn và tỳ lệ là động không dự dụng hết tính năm,
của một cả thức nghiệp. Thế o việc làm và không tìm việc dù sánh sàng làm,
vẫn ở mức 3 phẩy chính phần chăm, tương đơn hơn 2 trộng người.
Tương nhập bình quân quân của người là động trong khuy 2 đặt tám phy 2 trộng một tháng,
giảm nhẹ sò với quy một nhiên tăng sò với cùng khi năm ngoan.
Mức thu nhập sứ các nhóm vẫn có sự chình lịch sóa dịch,
là động năm cao hư lữ và là động ở thình thị cao hư nông thôn.
Tình trạng hơn mười phần chăm thình yên thông học,
không làm đặt ra yêu cầu cấp phy phải đầy mạnh đào tạo miệ,
tạo việc làm rất lượng và cải thiện mua trường sống,
học tập, là động cho thi hiện hệ chế.